Усе це сміття могло б опинитися на сміттєзвалищі
або в кращому випадку згоріти на сміттєспалювальному заводі.
Однак уже рік, як я вдома сортую сміття і,
як люблять казати екоактивісти, даю йому друге життя.
Скло, метал і пластик я не викидаю, а ретельно мию,
просушую
і складаю в пакет.
На папері в Києві вже давно запровадили
двоконтейнерну систему збору відходів.
Ідеться про так звані контейнери-сітки, які повинні
стояти на подвір'ї поруч зі звичайними
контейнерами для змішаного сміття. Саме туди
я б мала викидати відсортовану сировину. Втім,
у моєму дворі спеціальних контейнерів не було і немає.
У комунальному підприємстві "Київкомунсервіс" пояснюють, чому так.
- Якщо їх немає, ви повинні до нас звернутися.
Ми маємо переглянути норми утворення по вашому будинку
або по будинку поруч і проінформувати,
куди ви можете розділяти відходи і куди можете складувати.
Усього по Києву розмістили 14 тисяч контейнерів
для твердих побутових відходів і лише 2,5 тисячі для сухої вторсировини.
Замість того, щоб шукати контейнери-сітки по чужих подвір’ях,
я везу пакети зі склом і пластиком на станцію "Україна без сміття".
Її послуги з прийому вторсировини
стали альтернативним способом з утилізації сміття
як для мене, так і для інших свідомих киян.
Дмитро, наприклад, вторсировину збирав кілька тижнів.
Власною автівкою в вихідний привіз відходи на сортувальну станцію.
- На жаль, поки що з ініціативи київської влади
чув лише, що хочуть зробити сміттєперобний завод,
але, на жаль, поки що чітких дій не бачив.
Мені здається, що контейнери, де можна сортувати
пластик, скло і деякі інші види побудових відходів,
мають стояти в кожному дворі і подвір’ї.
Наразі київські чиновники лише взялися
за розробку плану реалізації Національної стратегії поводження з відходами,
яку уряд затвердив ще восени 2017 року.
У липні 2019-го планують встановити
до трьох тисяч контейнерів для збору пластику та скла.
Зобов’язали перевізників інформувати населення
пілотних регіонів столиці про важливість сортування.
Окрім того, заявили про намір побудувати
сміттєпереробний комплекс потужністю 700 тисяч тонн на рік.
Утім, така ініціатива викликає багато запитань у екоактивістів.
- Влада не пояснює, скільки буде коштувати
вивезення сміття на сміттєпероробку.
Якщо воно буде значно дорожче, то
з'явиться вже цікавість сортувати відходи.
Економічно, тому що можна відсортувати
і віднести в пункт прийому вторсировини або на станцію
і скоротити кількість свого сміття. Тут же про це мова не йде.
Як сплачували 20 гривень за вивизення, так і залишиться. А це неправильно.
Нині у Києві викидають понад 1 мільйон 300 тисяч тонн сміття на рік.
Лише 20% спалюється на заводі.
Решту захоронюють на околицях Києва.
Утім, кволо стратегію утилізації вторсировини втілюють у життя не лише в Києві,
а в цілому по Україні. Запуск сучасної системи утилізації сміття
буксується як через непрописане законодавство,
так і через відсутність штрафів та загалом слабку мотивацію населення.